hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video what
we're going to talk about is how to work
with circles and segment lengths as they
relate to circles so we've got a few
different formulas here and I've tried
to group them and explain the formulas
in a simple way so let's see if we can
go through them one by one and then
we'll do some examples so the first one
is when you have two chords okay they
cross inside a circle not necessarily at
the center what you'll find is is that
okay the two segments they cut each
other into two pieces right so they're
they're cutting each other but not
necessarily in half but if you take the
product of the two pieces
you know you multiply those two segment
lengths together it will equal the
product of the other two segments pieces
multiplied together so you can see like
a times B equals C times D so I just try
to make it real simple so a times B
equals C times D okay the next form that
we're gonna work with is when you have
to secant so a secant cuts through the
circle at two points okay and the way
I've written in here I think this is an
easy way to remember it is you take the
whole length of C cat number one times
the external part the part outside the
circle okay and that equals the whole
length of secant number two times the
part that's outside the circle so I just
call it hole one times external one
equals hole two times external - okay so
I'll easy to remember the whole secant
length times the part outside equals the
other hole seeking length times its part
outside and then the last one is when
you have a secant and a tangent you take
the whole secant length times the
external part
okay the part outside the circle equals
the tangent squared okay so the whole
length times external part equals the
length of the tangent times itself
tangent squared let's look at some
examples and I'll show you what I mean
so on this one we've got two chords and
we're just trying to solve for X so very
easy all we have to do is say 3 times 8
equals 4 times ax so this is 24 equals
4x so you can see X must equal
if you want sometimes what's helpful is
to pause the video try to see if you can
work out some of these examples and then
check yourself to see if you did it
right or you can just watch along no
problem so let's take a look at this one
here so now we've got to see khun's okay
we want to find this missing length here
as long as you know three of the four
parts no problem you can solve for them
the missing part right so what we're
gonna do is we're going to take this
whole length here and this is where
students sometimes go off the tracks
they'll say nine times three but we
actually want the whole length which is
nine plus three so that's 12 K times the
external part which is three K equals
this whole length okay which is two plus
X times the part outside the circle
which is two okay so again you don't
want to take like these two parts
multiplied together like we did in this
problem with the two cords you actually
want to add these two pieces together
now sometimes it'll give you that whole
length sometimes you have to add them
together but it's the whole times
external equals the whole times the
external okay so if we simplify this we
get 36 equals four plus 2x all I did was
distribute okay subtract four which is
32 equals 2x divided by 2x equals 16 so
that would be the length of that segment
right there okay that cord okay the last
example we've got secant and a tangent
so it just touches a circle at one point
so that's a tangent again we want to
take this whole length here we're using
this third formula down here at the
bottom we take the whole length which is
4 plus 12 which is 16 times the external
part which is 4 okay equals the tangent
squared so x times X which is x squared
so we have 64 equals x squared take the
square root of both sides x equals 8 all
right well I hope you're enjoying these
videos subscribe to the channel comment
below if you have some comments some
ways that I can make these videos more
helpful for you give me a thumbs up and
I'll talk to you in the next video I'll
talk to you soon